hallo lernen sie auch deutsch
ja ich habe mich jetzt gerade für einen
deutschkurs angemeldet
in welchem kurs gehen sie denn
in den dritten intensivkurs b 1
das ist kein zufall
ich komme
auch in den dritten intensivkurs
wir sind klassenkameraden
mein name ist markt am see
wie heißen sie
mein name ist nicole
ich gehe jetzt in ein café kommen sie
mit haben sie zeit haben sie zeit ja
klar
entschuldigung wie war doch gleich ihr
name kam sie aber machen jedoch du
ziehst lassen wir das mit dem sie freut
mich nackig bin nicole
guten tag was möchten sie bestellen ich
hätte gern einen milchkaffee ja gerne
und was kann ich ihnen bringen für mich
bitte einen grünte haben sie kuchen
selbstverständlich wir haben apfel oder
schokoladenkuchen
dann bin ich bitte noch ein stück
schokoladenkuchen klar
ich bringe ihnen gleich die bestellung
woher kommst du nach
ich komme aus thailand aus hua hin warst
du schon einmal in thailand vor drei
jahren war ich in thailand